c'est que je suis une sorte de communion
affublé d'un et vermillon que l'on voit
au cirque des quartiers vous vous
trompez lourdement
je vais peuvent ni dans le bus devraient
conforter j'ai la mission d'achever
votre vie vous appuyez tout sourit au
plus profond de vous même plus de filles
savoir que ça allait se terminer mieux
vous que ça se passe aujourd'hui
c'est quoi ce délire
ce soir nous allons faire une partie de
et tout ce que vous avez à faire c'est
survivre 12 heures entre les murs de
notre propre petit enfer sur terre pour
tous et des enfants de ciani en défense
leur phase de poules
les jeux sont faits rien ne va plus le
cours du riz ou pour ses parts à
l'instar
à
le 31 c'est au coeur
la terre
pendant faire que je vous adore le forme